J Happ is on the mound for the Cardinals
and it's start number 30 for the Lefty
yeah and I'll tell you what we talked
about him earlier today and talked about
them in the uh pregame and he's done
such a nice job
on a hop here to short call the young to
his left over to Matt Carpenter getting
a started first base today I mean he's
got something for you and look he's not
afraid to go inside
and the Fly ball lifted to Dylan Carlson
in Center for out number two brings it
home We're Gonna Fly ball in the left
field but right at the left field around
the numbers for Brett Anderson
it has been a rough finish to the season
for him Rock he'd like to go out with a
bang here today in the Finish strong in
2021.
start for him since coming off the
injured list
Evan flies to right for out number one
as Taylor puts it away Anderson's 1-1
Swain about your double play ball Adamas
to urius back over to Hira it is a
double play 6-4-3 it goes and Brad
Anderson turns two to end the inning 3-1
pitch swinging another off the end of
the bat finds the vacant area on the
right side of the infield so base hit
for Tyrone Brewers turn to double play
how about the Cardinals that is well hit
into left Center backing up Dylan
Carlson to make the catch
first strikeout for Jay Happ
all Carpenter goes to Second and Matt
not realizing
potentially that half could get there
but also everybody not realizing that
that's out number three thirds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the 1-1 and the young lifts it in
the air out to a deep left center it's
at the wall and off the ball a base of
the wall Coronado is going to be held up
at third
and quickly back into the infield as
Paul De Young was a few feet away from
his 20th home run and second and third
no one out
Juan Jones with a Fly ball into Center
backing up Jackie Bradley Jr Runners
will tag one will score that's arronado
into young the third and it's one
nothing Cardinals
that's a hot one right too Rios makes
the play
Kisner drives one towards right field
Tyrone Taylor angling towards the line
with a play makes the catch in Fair
territory in the inning ends back to the
top of the order that'll bring up Luis
1-1 pitch
High Drive deep right field rondone
going back at the track he looks up and
bye-bye baseball that falls into the
Cardinals Bullpen who Reyes homers for
the second time in this series and for
the 23rd time this year and the Brewers
have tied it at one and the Brewers
using the long ball here to tie the game
up at one two down now for Dylan Carlson
I Fly ball in a deep left center it's at
the wall
Devin Carlson Home Run number seven teen
his 52nd extra base hit in his rookie
season to tie Stan the Man and what he
did in his rookie year pretty Exclusive
Company Cardinals back on top it's 2-1
Omar narvaya is coming up
Brewers would love to get going he hits
how it hard into right that's down a
base hit Escobar will score easily
Taylor to second base the Brewers tie it
up as Narvaez jumping on the first pitch
here is keston Hira now first game in
the big leagues since late July
right off the end of the bat a broken
bat base hit for Hira Taylor around
third on his way to the plate throw his
cut off and keston hero with an RBI
single welcome back to the big leagues
it gives the Brewers the lead here in
the fourth inning
1-0 Swain line right base hit left
center field
Escobar is going to turn second he's
headed for third he's going to make it
there standing up Tyrone Taylor holds it
first he's three for three to a rally
here for the Brewers brings Omar Narvaez
to the play Brewers trying to add to
their 3-2 lead here's the ground ball
Shortstop on a second base side and
throwing the first teams out of his
first place
bouncing ball right to keston hero and
there is out number one Anderson has
settled in to to pinch swinging a
bouncer to second base easy for Urias
he's got it takes care of Andrew Kisner
want it to the count and he got him half
Strikes Out inning is over
3-1 pitch to Tommy Edmond Edmond rips it
and hit number 166. football smoked
Dylan Carlson homered his last time up
Carlson hits it into deep right and his
second home run Dylan Carlson Home Run
number 18. he's homered from both sides
of the plate what a talent
well they answered that in a big way and
there's a strikeout
strikeout on the inside corner and two
for Whitley coming in relief McFarland
throwing in the St Louis Bullpen and the
1-2 pitch reached four shallow left
O'Neal sliding and makes the catch for a
nice play right there tell you what when
this kid wants to play when he comes to
play he's a pretty good player I mean
it's it goes without notice that we talk
about it so much it's just the tools
that the Tyler O'Neill has there's your
ground ball
Edmund out there back to First what else
what else would TJ McFarland a ground
ball and a double play just like new bar
said the other day he can't come in a
game without getting a ground ball
double play TJ McFarland threw one pitch
and got two outs what else a double play
is 12 ground ball double play since the
All-Star break so the Cardinals leading
by a run as we head to the ninth
hero with a high fly ball into right
Carlson with the catch up against the
wall and the first out here in the ninth
Brewers down a run got a man on and
Lorenzo Kane will be the pinch hitter
for Jackie Bradley Jr
[Applause]
giving him a big hand and now standing
for what they hope will be the last out
swing and a miss Paul gets away from
Kisner he'll tag Wong and the Cardinals
take two of three and they win it by the
final of 4-3 today
[Applause]